okay green I need to let somebody go
today they told me I need to let
somebody go and as much as I think
you're great guy and I like you you're
you're good bye
let's fight it hmm let's call Jan and
fight this thing together like the old
days about old days what are you talking
about did you start the paperwork yet
it's right here on the desk you don't
have to do this Michael like I can't
undo it
no you're all good
great okay Ryan you told Toby the Creed
has a distinct old man smell I know
exactly what he's talking about i sprout
mung beans on a damp paper towel in my
desk drawer very nutritious but they
smell like death can I ask you all
question do you know what it's like to
be disabled when I was a teenager I was
in an iron lung Wow how old are you that
is Northern Lights cannabis indica no
it's marijuana
there's greed let's take a look at what
he's doing everybody this is creed and
he is in charge of something right
correct say hi to the kids hi kids
yeah you ever seen a foot with four toes
[Music]
no no would you cut it out oh I steal
things all the time
it's just something I do I stopped
carrying a long time ago
you should see how many supplies I've
taken from this place honestly I love
stealing things I'm not offended by
homosexuality in the sixties I made love
to many many women off
outdoors in the mud and the ring and as
possible a man slipped in would be no
way of knowing I run a small fake ID
company from my car with a laminating
machine that I swiped from the sheriff's
station
it's real shame about it huh yeah must
really have you thinking about what the
older you get the bigger the chances
you're gonna die you know that ed was
decapitated
he was drunk as a skunk he was flying
down Route six he slides under an
18-wheeler pop it snaps right off that
is the way to go
instant death very smart you know a
human can go on living for several hours
after being decapitated you thinking I'm
a chicken what did I say
[Music]
go back down
[Music]
extraordinary events call for
extraordinary actions we form an
allegiance to use sudden violence do you
have the tools to turn a wooden mop
handle into a steak which size and the
winner is Andy Bernard with 14 hot dogs
one came up their date hot dogs
everybody Oh nobody told me we're gonna
have hot dogs I find it offensive
unnatural baby that's how I like him
swing low Sweet Chariot you know what
don't even worry about it
everyone was so drunk but no one even
remembers what you said I remember I
blogged the whole thing WWE thought Co V
W W backslash Creed thoughts check it
out
last year Creed asked me how to set up a
blog wanting to protect the world from
being exposed to Creed's brain I opened
up a word document on his computer and
put an address at the top I've read some
of it even for the internet it's pretty
shocking that's why we're cursed I've
been involved in a number of cults both
as a leader and a follower get more fun
to follow her but you make more money as
a leader okay name please
creed bratton 75-plus division you're
over 75 years old 82 November 1st how
much is the price money there's no prize
but is any of this real we're screwed
I was us you and me the old timers I am
NOT old you are old
like 100 you're over 40 that's the
cutoff are you listening to what he's
saying
retraining new system Youth I'm telling
you this kid is the grim reaper you deal
with this or you me Sammy Phyllis the
chickie it with a car were goners
Creed yes sir
everything okay everything is cool dude
I'm 30 well in November I'll be 30 the
pleasure is all mine
no thanks I'm really looking forward to
sitting down with you and finding out
more about what you do here anytime yeah
what do you do here excuse me what is
wrong with this woman she's asking about
stuff that's nobody's business what do I
do
probably what do I do here I should have
written it down cause I'm Dean quad
quartz quad Bow Wow
Clark Labadee Quality Assurance No hey
cousin heard you're having money
problems no you didn't listen I got the
answer you declare bankruptcy all your
problems go away
Creed Bratton has never declared
bankruptcy when Creed rat and gets in
trouble he transfers his debt to William
Charles Schneider nobodies just from
creed bratton gets away with it
the last person to do this disappeared
his name great breath we were tipped off
about a possible narcotic situation here
BAM hey I got this okay hello officers
Dwight Schrute former volunteer
sheriff's deputy listen I may have
inside information that someone is
hiding drugs in this very office
just pretend like we're talking until
the cops leave so hey I wanna set you up
with my daughter
oh I'm engaged to Pam if that you were
gay then why would you want to set me up
with her daughter
I don't know Stanley that I have asked
cuz I don't if it gets out and they
won't let me scuba if I can't scuba then
what's this all been about what am i
working toward sorry boss what's going
on sir
there has been a murder and you are a
suspect oh okay
hang on just sick let me settle in and
I'll be right back very good very good
now no one was there in the wine cellar
hatred and you read Chinese better in
English what does this say hi MA
yo gun Joel one cow
it's a beautiful morning at
dunder-mifflin as I like to call it
great Bratton keep it running do I love
being manager I love my kids I love real
estate
I love ceramics I love my job I love
wrestling I saw a friend today it had
been a while
we forgot each other's name but he
didn't matter cuz deep inside feelings
still remain the same it all seems so
very arbitrary I applied for a job at
this company because they were hiring
I took a desk at the back because it was
empty but no matter how you get there or
where you end up human beings have this
miraculous gift to make that place home
let's do this
you